even in death even with half of his head
blown
clean away his body refuses to yield
his mighty figure cutting swathes
through his foes
was truly monstrous and over the course
of his battles he received a full 267
blade wounds
the bullets he endured totaled 152
and the cannonballs he has withstood
amount to 46
and yet upon the proud bag of this
legendary man
or indeed upon his very life as a pirate
he bears
no single wound of cowardice
if you want to find an example of a
truly perfect supporting character
you need look no further than edward
newgate aka whitebeard
and his role in the story of one piece
oda does
a wonderful job of making him one of the
most badass and influential characters
in the series
and he does it in a very interesting way
he introduces whitebeard as the
strongest pirate in the series
while at the same time utilizing every
single aspect of his character
as a powerful storytelling device as you
might know
many supporting characters in your
average story usually serve
at least one of two purposes make them
interact with the main character
so we can engage with them and thus
advance the story
or supply us with some new pieces of
information about the world that our
story takes place
in with whitebeard oda does
both he uses the emperor to vastly
expand our understanding of the one
piece world
and sets the stage for the second half
of the plot in the new world
and at the same time oda also flashes
out his character to be one of the most
important
and powerful players in the story and i
believe that this
was a really smart move because what
makes whitebeard
so popular and exciting as a character
at least on the surface
is not what he teaches us about the
world but who he is
as a person the strongest man alive
the pirate respected and feared by all
and the man who went head to head with
the world government
by starting the world the best and so i
think it's
more than just adequate that in this
video we will be discussing not one
but two aspects of whitebeard's
character how he drastically expanded
our view of the one piece worlds
and why he was the next unofficial
pirate king
after goldie roger
before i go and explain how ingeniously
oda has used whitebeard as a
world-building element and how critical
he was in setting up the second half of
the story
i think i first have to justify myself
for saying that whitebeard was the
second pirate king
that's a pretty bold statement after all
believe me
i know but if you bear with me here i
promise it will
all make sense once we make it to the
end of this video
so let's start from zero and steadily
build our way towards pirate king
material
because to truly understand whitebeard's
character
we first have to understand the
underlying theme around which oda has
created his design
idealism if i made you forget everything
you knew about edward newgate and his
actions in the story
and then asked you to think about what
the ideal pirate in one piece for you
would
look like i bet most people would come
up with either one of two categories
power or personality after all what sets
luffy apart from
other characters in the story are pretty
much these two things there are
a number of characters that are as
compassionate and strong-willed as luffy
and there are also many characters that
are as strong or maybe even stronger
than him
and so in the end what really makes
luffy so unique
is that he's both however while luffy
still has to grow as a person over the
course of the story
and has to train in order to become
stronger with whitebeard
oda shows us what an ideal candidate for
pirate king should look like in the end
i strongly believe that he's the
ultimate role model in terms of strength
and character for luffy to follow
and so let's take a look in detail at
how oda created whitebeard within these
two categories
when whitebeard was first introduced way
back in chapter
234 oda gave him the epithet of
strongest man in the world
for a reason while i think it's fair to
debate whether he was
actually stronger than roger whether
kaido as the strongest creature in the
world might have been even more powerful
and whether he was already way beyond
his primate marine fort
i think what isn't up for debate is that
for
at least two decades edward newgate was
the most powerful human in the one piece
world
periods on the most basic level
this was of course due to his enormous
physical strength
equipped with powerful haki and of
course due to his powerful devil fruit
the guru guru nomi
that is said to hold the power to
destroy the entire world
in all the encounters he has a marine
fort whether it be a kainu or blackbeard
he always seems to have the edge despite
his countless wounds and illnesses
and of course we could witness his true
power in his clashes with odin and roger
both of which were considered to be
monsters themselves in terms of brute
strength
additionally he was a more than capable
swordsman
wielding one of the 12 supreme nato
swords that he most likely turned into a
black blade over his lifetime
but beyond these monstrous physical
abilities
whitebeard also held enormous tactical
power
as one of the yonko he commanded an
enormous crew
and an even larger fleet of affiliated
pirates
and especially after roger's execution
and the end of the rivalry
whitebeard who also had the second
highest bounty after roger
used his personal and military power and
in combination with a very sharp and
tactical mind
to ultimately be the one to control
large parts of the oceans
and to keep the balance in the new world
just
how strong his grip on the world
actually was became
especially clear after the war where as
a result of his death
the balance of the world was dealt a
devastating blow
countless islands under his protection
fell into anarchy and were invaded by
other pirates
and the power vacuum he left behind gave
room for new players to gain influence
in the new world
including the likes of luffy and
blackbeard
and speaking of whitebeard's legacy his
death at marineford
in my opinion might be one of the most
misunderstood scenes in the entire story
many people like to accuse whitebeard of
not being the man he once was at
marineford
and as a result badly overestimating his
own strength
however as i see it oda made it pretty
much
clear that he never had the intention of
surviving the war in the first place
instead it should be his ultimate proof
of pride and power
in other words whitebeard went to
marineford
to die he purposefully removed the
medication he was hooked to that was
keeping him alive
he joined the fight heads on without any
regard for his health or his life
to prove to the world that he could
still fight with the big shots
the thing that whitebeard feared the
most then was being pitied for his
condition
and so he decided that he'd rather go
out with a bang rather than
slowly waste away on board of his ship
his true intention for the war then
was to free ace and make him his
successor
and the top candidate for the next
pirate king and so this
in my opinion is one of the strongest
displays of honor
strength and will that we've seen in all
of one piece
outside of the straw hats another point
i think is important to make when
considering oda's portrayal of
whitebeard
is his source of inspiration for the
character in the first place
primarily there are two major characters
whose attributes have been united in the
emperor
the first is the real life blackbeard
his character has been an inspiration
for both
white and blackbeard for two reasons
first his name edward teach which oda
has split into
edward newgate and marshall d teach
and secondly his reputation as one of
the most infamous real pirates in our
worlds
and what this shows us is that oda has
actively chosen the most recognizable
example of a true pirate
as the basis for whitebeard's character
but there is also a second figure
this time from japanese folklore that
also plays a major role here
i'm speaking of the character of benkei
a legendary japanese warrior monk
who was said to have lived in the latter
years of the heian period in the 12th
century
benkei was notoriously known for his
superhuman strength
as well as his strong sense of loyalty
the monk was said to be at least
five times the size of a normal man and
wielded a
naginata as his weapon of choice the
same long-range type of blade
as murakumogiri the blade at whitebeard
wheels
however the deep bencai is most known
for
is dying against an overwhelming force
of enemies
standing upright and riddled by arrows
and spears
oda chose these obvious parallels for a
reason
they are what make whitebeard into the
proud strong
and fearless pirate that he is only he
being roger's equal would have been able
to start a second era of piracy
because to become pirate king one needs
to be a true ideal of strength and power
now while willpower strength and
influence are certainly basic
requirements for becoming pirate king
there are actually a number of
candidates that would fall into this
category
that literally nobody would want to see
on top of the food chain
except for ryan what the hell's wrong
with you ryan
so what makes roger or luffy different
from let's say
a blackbeard or a kaido i would argue
that it's compassion and kindness that
makes for an ideal pirate king
at least in my and probably also oda's
eyes
both roger and luffy represent the
quote-unquote good pirate
that helps the weak and strives for
justice freedom and happiness
and that's what sets them apart from
other strong characters in one piece
and therefore i think that this also
serves as an argument that whitebeard
also held the unofficial role of pirate
king as he's not only an ideal of power
and strength
but also of compassion and kindness
while he easily could have reached love
tale as well he
never cared to find the one piece in the
first place
what newgate was actually looking for
was to form strong relationships and to
find the family
that he was denied as a child growing up
as an orphan
while we do not know yet what he was
like during his time with the rox
pirates
at least by the time he started his own
crew he was a cheerful and carefree
young pirate roaming the seas
his primary mission in life was
protecting the weak
and he did so by putting entire islands
under his flag
and by recruiting lost men into his crew
by adopting them as his sons
he did so with squirt who lost his
entire crew to roger
with ace with blackbeard and many others
that didn't have any other place to go
he also did not care much for race or
status
and was the only one willing to stand up
for the fishmen
and end their exploitation through the
humans
and i think another trait that shows
whether someone is a truly great leader
is by looking at how they treat their
people compared to many of the other
yonko
whitebeard had a truly great crew
kaido for instance seems to rule over
his men through power
and fear blackbeard has surrounded
himself with people
hungry for power and blood and big mom
actually has made her real family into
her crew
but doesn't even get close to the level
of warmth and joy
that the whitebeard pirates had the
secret behind this
is that whitebeard has built his crew
predominantly
on trust love and respect thus
similar to his inspiration benkei
loyalty
is the major theme of the whitebeard
pirates which is also what makes
blackbeard's betrayal of said loyalty
the ultimate crime for the crew and
something i feel is directly connected
to this idea
is the strong moral code that newgate
has loyalty and respect
are what the emperor values most highly
what makes him different from let's say
a kainu however who
actually shares surprisingly similar
ideals
is that whitebeard has the ability to
forgive
in that sense the scene with squirt is
actually
way more important for whitebeard's
characterization than you might have
realized
despite betraying his trust and loyalty
just as blackbeard did
and stabbing him through the back
whitebeard forgives him by being
compassionate and understanding his true
motivations
because while blackbeard betrayed him
for power squirt was manipulated by a
kainu
into believing that he would be
sacrificed for aces sake
the fact that whitebeard is actually
able to distinguish between these two
cases
is pretty much the exact opposite to a
kindness concept of
absolute justice which is also why the
conflict between the two
works so wonderfully well they in fact
do share
a number of views and values but in the
decisive
area of morality they're the complete
opposite of each other
it is also no wonder then that
whitebeard quickly grew to enormously
respect
luffy odin and roger all of which share
these two fundamental traits of strength
and compassion as well
and could thus change the world for the
better and this
is exactly why i believe that while he
never even tried to find the one piece
in the first
place after roger's death whitebeard
effectively became the next pirate king
and ruler of the seas the point here is
of course not
that whitebeard was exactly like roger
just as
roger was never exactly like luffy this
would not only make little sense
but would also be extremely boring no
each of the three has of course their
unique personality and a unique path to
follow
what unites them however are these
central traits that oda presents to us
as the requirements to become the ideal
pirates
or in other words the stuff that makes a
pirate king
so now that we've discussed how oda has
created the in my
opinion fantastic character of
whitebeard in the context of the story
in the last part of this video i want to
explore how this character
also serves as a strong device for world
building
and what we've discussed so far
hopefully will help you understand
better
what makes all of this so genius because
in more than just one way the
introduction of whitebeard as a
character
also introduced to us several crucial
aspects of the one piece world
that were desperately needed to progress
the plot
first of all whitebeard introduced to us
the old generation
through his actions and fights we were
able to witness the monstrous power that
the likes of roger
garb and rox must have held when they
were roaming the seas during their prime
it gives us a sense of way greater
powers being at work in the one piece
world than we originally thought
physical and political conflicts
suddenly were on a completely
different level and this already brings
me to my second point
setting a new standard this new spectrum
of strength and influence that came with
whitebeard and his war against the
marines
was introduced as a new measuring stick
for luffy and the crew to strive towards
it showed us just how much there was
still to learn and to explore
and how far they actually still were
from getting even close to playing at
the top level
in retrospect it was oda basically
shouting at us that a typescape was
about to come
and that luffy needed a significant
change in character
and a new drive to become stronger
whitebeard's death meanwhile
rang in the end of this old era and gave
rise to the new
one making space for luffy and also
others to grow in
this of course also included blackbeard
whose character arc
in many ways has been about opposing and
ultimately killing off
the last remaining ideal pirate and thus
pushing luffy to fill this newly created
vacuum
so not only did whitebeard significantly
expand our understanding of the
one-piece world
but he also set up the entirety of the
new world saga by giving the story
a fresh start and at the same time with
blackbeard
introducing the ultimate antagonist for
luffy that in more than just one way
can be considered the anti-pirate king
that needs to be kept away from gaining
power
at all costs after all what we want
is an ideal pirate king what we want is
someone as worthy for the title
as the strongest man in the world
another character that has had enormous
impact on luffy and his journey is
another emperor
shanks you can find out what his role in
the story is and what role nordic
mythology plays for his character
by clicking right here peace guys